j'ai vu cette affaire de décret est là
tout ça bon
nous avons suivi une procédure j'ai que
j'ai pas signer le décret parce que
c'est en attendant la toussaint alors
qu'il était prêt non j'ai signé le
décret sans me rends compte de la date à
laquelle on n'était pas ce que je
pouvais pas imaginer qu'il y aura un
procès sur le fait que c'était signal à
tout ça d'ailleurs moi je j'ai fini par
l'ignorer totalement ce que sont les
jours fériés non férié depuis longtemps
dont je signe tous les jours des décrets
quand il m'arrive je me pose pas la
question de savoir si vous mange les
signes c'est le moment opportun raison
de l'interprétation qui peut être fait
de la dap parce que je m'intéresse moi à
la date à laquelle je signe que au
contenu de ce que je signe et donc très
franchement j'ai vu que en catimini nous
aurions signé un décret pour être
désagréable non nous avons signé un
décret au terme d'une procédure que j'ai
décrit le jour où il m'a été présenté je
dois d'ailleurs vous dire que si j'avais
pensé qu'à un moment ce procès de la
toussaint puissent m'être fait je
l'aurai signée
quatre jours après ou trois jours avant
tout ça est pour moi bon jeu j'entends
un mais
moi je ne suis pas plus en catimini à la
toussaint qu'à la pentecôte que le 3
avril ou que le 4 décembre parce que
pour moi tout ça ce sont les mêmes jours
fait de labeur de travail de signature
de parapheurs et et de concentration
donc je vous rassure là-dessus il n'y a
pas de perversité du jour férié au
ministère de l'intérieur sur les sujets
importants